and we are back in its traditional April
slot the first time since a 2019. over
the next two days we'll be holding a
number of press conferences with our
star athletes who will be taking part in
the incredible set of elite races on
Sunday morning getting this underway is
our British men's press conference which
I'm delighted to be joined on stage by
the new European 10 Mile record holder
Emil caress a a man who doesn't seem to
age two-time Olympian Chris Thompson and
a runner that needs little introduction
probably the best British runner of all
time four-time Olympic champion six
times world champion also the British
Marathon record holder so Mo Farah and
we're delighted to have them on stage we
have the media in the room as well as
those online the media in the room those
looking to ask questions to our three up
on stage please raise your hands give
your name give your organization and
then obviously your question for those
online please submit your questions to
the online chat and Ryan will be asking
those questions after those in the room
get their chance for the media online if
we could ask them to please keep their
microphones turned on mute for the whole
time of the press conference thank you
very much so first a chance to ask our
athletes how their preparation has gone
I'll start with a meal a fantastic 2022
your 2023 has started in uh fantastic
fashion as well have your final
preparations gone ready for Sunday's GCS
London Marathon
um yeah everything's gone well I I've
managed to do all the training there I
plan to when that happens I think you
can't ask for any more than that every
session's gone well so I'm really
looking forward to the weekend
and Chris how are the legs feeling ready
for Sunday yeah that's refreshing to
hear a young person be so positive
because it's a bit harder at my age to
to be 100 like that but yeah I think
it's been been a decent build up as I
was saying to a meal on driving from the
photos
um it's hard to have a anyone build up
the same it's all it seems like a
different Journey every time this is my
eighth marathon and I'm just intrigued
to see what happens I'm hoping this will
set me up for the year
um I don't know if I've nailed every
session like this chap has but um as
I've learned from marathons that doesn't
for me personally doesn't mean
everything so I'm just excited to be
here and be in the middle of these two
and hopefully uh
give it a bash and see if I can mix it
up
and for yourself Mo obviously you know
cast your mind back to October you got
within a few sessions didn't you of toe
in the line
um and obviously injury put you out of
that race
um how was your recovery your time off
and how's preparation gone for Sunday
yeah no um last year I was definitely
got it uh I was in decent chair we just
got injured just a week before the
London Marathon but that's that's
Athletics it happens but this year I'm
back and I'm healthy which is the key
thing for me I've been out in Ethiopia
and training has gone well so
hopefully let's see what we can do
so we're delighted to have you three
towing the line on Sunday we've got some
fantastic press in the room so we're
opening the questions out to the floor
we've got Ruby and Jake out on the floor
with microphones so who would ask the
first of our questions to our top three
on the table
my phone to John
hi there uh Jonathan Gault here from
let's run.com question for Mo
um I'm wondering if you could tell us
about your recent race in Gabon how
indicative do you think that result was
of your Fitness and did it concern you
at all coming into this race yeah I had
a little run in Gabon as a 10k race I
went out there while I was in Ethiopia
race was just kind of just test myself
and see you know what I can do but
climate was really hot there
um always the key was you know to
prepare for the London Marathon had a
lot of miles in my leg but at the same
time it's just you know that race was
kind of thinking didn't go as well as I
wanted but you've got to go and move on
and get ready for the next one and and
now I'm healthy and hopefully be ready
on Sundays see what we can do
it doesn't worry you at all not at all
not at all um I think you've got to look
at the uh not just one race but you've
got to look through your training
consistency and and for me the biggest
thing is being able to do the training
for so many weeks which you know my
body's allowing me which is the main
thing and and I've done some decent
training over the last couple of months
so I'm happy in terms of why I'm in my
training and I guess
hopefully just now you know he's done
he's done this week and then just go
into it
thank you Mo
Le Guardian um question for Mo first
then a question four of you bro how
close have your workouts been with
Bashir given his run last week 203 and
if so does like give you confidence for
Sunday and I guess secondly
do you have any plans to do the world's
uh Marathon this summer and same
question to you guys if you do well this
Sunday yeah
first of all I want to definitely
congratulate my teammate but she Abdi
who won Rotterdam comfortably uh two
zero three and looked like he could have
gone not run a lot faster
and I was very proud of him to see you
know what he could do because as a kid I
remember him you know first of all
training with him and over the years you
know he's always kind of kept pushing
and kept learning from me and to see
someone achieve that I have to be very
proud and and in terms of myself I was
definitely I'm definitely confident that
seeing him what you could do and what I
could do now it does definitely inspire
me and give me a massive confidence and
not just him but also Abdi negate who
finished third in 205 so we're in the
same group and go back to your questions
in terms of sessions we're pretty close
neck and neck times I wasn't I wasn't
always the one pushing but you know I
was there about and like that's
definitely give me a big confidence but
the key thing is you know
just focusing your own thing we'll see
what you can do but seeing that that
definitely give me a massive boost and a
confidence
yeah they go next to your second
question sorry uh the world championship
I'm having I'm not thinking anything
other than this race I have got a plan
to do a couple of more races after that
uh but get London out the way and then
and finger and in terms of world Champs
I don't plan to you know to go out there
and race
it was the world Champs question
yeah
uh so
you can't really because we don't have a
policy that
there's no result tomorrow I could run
on Sunday that means I go uh guaranteed
or anything like I could win the race in
203 and then I'd still have to wait for
them to decide so there's no point
worrying about
um
about whether I about trying to go
because there's no clear
um sign that that any one of us will get
a selection regardless of our result and
so as sport does control the
controllables after this race I don't
know what the rest I genuinely don't
know what the rest of my year holds and
so I'll see off the back of the result
what may come of that but at the moment
I'm personally sounds boring and cliche
but I'm just trying to get the best out
of myself on Sunday and I finally feel
like such wood over the next couple of
days locked myself in the room I can put
last year and the two mess-ups with the
mouth and that behind me and
actually
uh still try and do something I'm proud
of because even though I am I turned 42
there's no there's no getting around it
on Monday
yeah I had a birthday yeah
you got you got your 40 40 tag didn't
you
um and so like I I still even though
that's there in the background I'm still
have aspirations to do things I
technically haven't other than the drama
last year with the worlds I have made
the last two major Champs so we'll see
and I can't
worry about the next days until I uh and
just keep pushing it but I think yeah
that's kind of answers it I'm trying to
be open-minded
um I don't have any plans to do the
marathon at Budapest but hopefully I can
qualify for the 10 000 meters
um if everything goes to plan so yeah
that's what I'm hoping to dinner
somewhere
Joe
hi it's Jennifer and BBC how are you Mo
I'm good thank you it's great to see you
here again and I know how much it means
to the marathon and to the people of
London to have you back in this race two
questions really how does it feel to you
to be back in the London Marathon
secondly been a lot in the news this
week about protests at sporting events
I'm sure you've seen it do you have any
extra concern this year about security
and safety in the marathon
no first of all it's nice to be back in
London I love London and this is from
his home this is where my journey
started when I was a young boy doing the
mini marathon and I remember you
interviewed me before so it's always
nice to come back here
um and I do enjoy London and hopefully
Sunday I'm looking forward to seeing the
crowd and the people atmosphere and I
think the key thing is just go out there
enjoy it and as I said I've not seen too
much because the last two months I was
at an Ethiopia training and at times we
would have
power car we wouldn't have TV so I'm
just kind of just concentrating training
and playing games with you know with the
boys I've not seen too much of it but I
think in terms of sports myself as I
said always thinking next Legacy what
could do what we can do and I think it's
nice to see a manual a minute sorry
joining us and and seeing what he could
do that 10 Mile and seeing how the
attitude of you know athletes are
changing and seeing the work ethic that
goes into it and I think self-belief as
well it's a big thing so it's just nice
to see from as I said from an afflu
who's been there and gone through the
ranks or you know trained uh in Ethiopia
Kenya and see what he's doing out there
basing himself in Kenya and trying to
learn from the best is is a great
attitude
but in terms of the race mode you'll
trust the organizers I guess to make
sure that everything goes smoothly
because I mean it always has in the past
so yeah for sure laughing London Martha
has always done a great job uh you look
over the years and what they've done and
I think they will continue to to you
know do a great great job and I guess
you just have to leave it to them but
I'm sure they'll do everything that they
can and and for me it's just been
excited to be back in London so it was
always great there's no better city than
London
yes
uh Rob Harrison Sky News just to follow
up on that
um there is all the sort of talk of
environmental process uh we saw at the
Grand National that was disrupted is it
a cause that actually means something to
you the fat people
think they're only route to maybe gain
attention for the crisis and the
environment is to protest at sports
is that for me Chris I think for all of
us we love seeing sport we love watching
our team and that's what we're
passionate about and I think so on
Sunday people want to see the best
athletes go out there and race and put
on a good show and I think for us as an
athlete we just have to go and do the
best that we can and concentrate on what
we do
um again I think Sports we all love
support
um and uh you trust the London marathon
and the officials that now always do a
great job
I was going to say like I I was sitting
there thinking about what you're saying
because I've seen a couple of them but I
feel like what a better statement for
all these causes than thousands of
people running the Streets of London for
health and well-being reasons and uh you
know we're racing running raising money
for charity I mean it's the race in
itself is a statement so I'd like to
think uh if anything London Marathon as
a sporting event stands out as a as a
something to Aspire to do I mean my
mum's running her first marathon this
weekend
um she pushed herself in ways she never
thought before
um and that to me just watching how
she's done that is a statement of intent
and what what physically running can do
for health and well-being and all these
different causes in itself but yeah so I
think I think the event itself is kind
of sets a precedence in a way
yeah I think uh because London Marathon
raises so much money for charity and
good causes although I think like the
environment is obviously another good
cause I don't think they should put
themselves
um in front of other good causes and
just sort of respect the the people
raising money for charity this weekend
and then I'm sure other people raising
money for Charlie this weekend will
respect the environmental cause at a
different time
all right Tom desperate from the times a
question for a meal as it's your debut
for the over the distance going into
Sunday I was just wondering if the
thinking is to just sort of learn the
distance sort of take in the day or of
you going in with sort of more of a race
targeted time Target in mind
uh I think it's a little bit both
obviously like any race I want to
perform the best and try and achieve a
Target but I think the primary objective
is to learn the rest and have a good
experience and then hopefully I can take
that to Future races where I can be more
competitive with the top guys and yeah
and so this is just a platform for that
I think I just saw the follow-up
question as well um you said you'll see
you want to focus more on the 10 000 for
the worlds would that be for thinking
going into Paris next year or would if
to the Sunday's race goes well would you
look to maybe go for the marathon for
the Olympic Games or would you rather
stick down with a short distance on the
track I definitely think the marathon is
where my future lies and yeah hopefully
if everything goes well I can try and be
a competitive in Paris in the marathon
um yeah I don't see my future on the
track but I feel like it's uh it's a
valuable like stepping stone that you
need to go through to be competitive in
the marathon so that's why I'm going to
be focusing on the track this summer and
yeah I'll always be doing short
distances regardless
even though I consider myself a marathon
runner thank you
Emil how much confidence did Valencia
last year obviously the 10 kilometer
equal British record and obviously the
half marathon
um 60 30. um how much confidence did
that give you into your preparation into
London I think they gave it they did
give me some confidence that things were
moving in the right direction but
um I trained really hard and I think all
my my training gives me the most
confidence that I see where my times are
at and how about Compares with like what
the top guys are doing and as long as
I'm moving closer to that each month and
I'm not too concerned about any
particular one race
um so yeah I'll just be looking to
better myself and all the all the
distances and stuff like that and keep
working hard and training and hopefully
yeah that'll just lead me to better
results
and have you got half an hour on the
Bradford grammar school Marathon record
uh yeah it'd definitely be a nice uh
nice thing to do but yeah Richard and
yeah all of his times are not easy to
beat I've had some difficulty in doing
that but yeah we'll just we'll see if
that comes but it's not it's not
something I'm too focused on yeah we
were joking off early because you
obviously took his 10 Mile record
recently but he claims he's got a lot of
uh the 12 and 30 mil records that can't
be beaten now so
yeah yeah I remember we have a few
courses it's cool and yeah Richard and
the brownies and a few of the guys are
yeah really quick times that yeah I
wasn't able to be but if if I can beat
them up and more yeah I'd value that a
little bit more but yeah we'll just see
what happens
brilliant any other questions on the
floor Jonathan again
another question for Mo you said earlier
this year that this is likely going to
be last year and when a lot of athletes
get towards the end of their career they
feel a different range of emotions what
emotions have you been feeling as you
train uh and you get near the end of
your career
yeah um
in quite emotional last couple of years
um you know and as after you always want
to go out there and do your do the best
that you can
um the last few years you know my body
hasn't been allowed me to do what I
needed to do in training and that's the
hardest thing you know I think even
myself I take take it for granted when
you're athlete and you you you you you
get to the top and when you get to the
top you don't change your routine you
just go
race after race training training each
year and for me for many many years like
eight eight or ten years you take it for
granted because you just think you just
keep it's almost like reprogramming just
you just keep going and keep going but
now as you get older
that that totally changes because your
body you can't do what you did or a
couple of years ago when you get injured
and for me that's been most frustrating
because
it's just like well nothing's changed
I've just been doing but you can't do it
because
it happens and then the last two years
it's definitely been tough and again as
I said even London last year just week
week and a half out
getting inches was hard because I see my
teammates he's a guy who's training and
going well and him finishing third and
you watching on telly going
but that's Athletics and I think the key
thing is for me is that if I as long as
they're injury-free and and be free and
can do the work then I will continue as
as you said but
my body's not allowing me and I think as
I said Sunday it was probably my last
marathon in terms of you know just being
realistic and and seeing it it will be
my last marathon uh it won't be my last
race but in terms of marathon I think
London Marathon will be my last and and
I started the mini marathon here so for
me
it'd be quite emotional because you I
remember 13 years old 14 years old
I was here watching you know great
athletes going on they're running on
Sunday and you're taking part in the
middle Marathon so
and the support that people when they
come out in London uh I think that will
get to me
um but I'll try not to think about it
and just just try and run and after the
race maybe there might be a bit of tears
and be emotional so you wouldn't run a
full Marathon then
this is it
is that I don't know if my body can do
it
um as I said
week and week out you finish this one
yeah
I'm gonna finish this one I have to
finish there's no question of a doubt uh
but yeah get this one out the way and
then this is it
okay you got me that I was like what did
I say
I assume we're gonna finish it we have
to do
yeah so it's a good question whilst Amir
was sat there in terms of longevity you
know you two have stayed you know at the
the peak of international performances
you're now Masters athletes
um battling out for the the Masters
championships at the weekend as well
what's your advice to a meal and what
what kept you coming back you talk about
the training mode you talk about you
know you know still putting the hard
work in how have you adapted things over
the last few years uh you know as ages
crept up on you
yeah now ages does catch up with you and
and your body is our if I were to give
any advice to menu uh is be able to just
you know keep keep working hard keep
believing yourself and you're still
young you've got you've got a future
ahead of you so don't be afraid he's
already putting yourself out there to be
the with the best guys in in Kenya so
just keep doing that and keep believing
yourself and just keep keep enjoying it
and um yeah don't take things for
granted that's what I would say myself I
think for many many years I took stuff
for granted and just being able to think
you could do it you could do it you
could do it and you keep doing it but
then you do get to a stage where
the body's not allowing you so just be
I'm sure he's got the right team behind
him and just keep enjoying it and live
that moment
um yeah I was drifting off thinking
about it but I think um yeah uh
I'd say first of all first of all like
because I haven't spent a huge amount of
time with you have I I I've spoken a few
times but I have to say I've been
watching I mean crikey we knew he said
14 I was thinking back I would have been
16 and
that's a different less than 90s it's a
different Century but anyway I digress
um and through the years I've seen well
we've both seen a lot of young athletes
come and go and um for me personally
I've not obviously hit those Heights of
Mo I've been proud to keep myself
somewhat in the game and somewhat
relevant
um over those years with highs and lows
um and you do see and I'm proud to have
sort of outlasted athletes who were much
younger but
Emil has got a presence about him that
re and the way you've talked that's
really impressed me and I think just
keep that because it's not often you get
an athlete
that's precocious but humble and and
ambitious and all the right blend of all
these different things and so I firstly
I want to commend you for that and I'm
actually genuinely excited to see what
you can do not just this weekend but
going forward and I will follow because
again
for we've all actually one thing we've
all got in common we've all been coached
by Alan I'm still by coach by Allen's
story you started your career with
Adam's story you had a good chunk with
Alan's story
um and so there was a bit of a
connection there but I think
for advice wise I would say
um
keep keep that hunger keep that sort of
naivety a little bit and don't let uh
the baggage of expectation and all these
things creep in and keep trying to
figure yourself out because when you get
older you'll rely on having to
constantly
re-learn yourself and re-learn to keep
yourself in the game like every year now
I'm trying to go what am I now what
what's my strength and weaknesses to
keep myself relevant as most as you're
constantly trying to figure that out and
your learning years are now but um I'm
more like impressed and I'm looking
forward to
see what you go on to do mate so yeah
thumbs up I'm saying that in front of
him but I said that even if they weren't
here honestly uh
sounds a bit mushy but it is nice it's
exciting I think it's this is one of the
most exciting and again this is not it's
one of these for me it is this weekend
with Elish and Emil to the most exciting
Marathon debuts I think British has seen
in a while and regardless of how they do
I think both of them could be here for a
while and do some exciting things yeah
yeah for sure as I said you're uh
English and also in terms of you know
what youngsters coming through they are
great athletes who you know have that
determination and when you see them
you're like yeah it could be someone
what's it like to be on stage with two
athletes that I'm sure you're a student
of the sport anyone that does no meal
was self-coached at certain points and
obviously sought out you know some great
advice and gone and found people to to
tap into like Alan like uh you know uh
Renato at the moment and and how is it
to be on the stage and now be on the
same start line and uh you know and in
that uh progression as yourself as an
athlete and someone that as I said is is
someone that is a lover of the sport
yeah it's a little bit surreal like to
be solemn's idea
the more difficult thing like doing the
social media or doing stuff like press
conference I think just taking all of
that on board it's a big uh it's a big
learning curve and yeah it's great to be
it's a great position to be in because
yeah if I'm starting next to these two
guys I'm doing something right
yeah not for sure any more questions on
the floor Ewan
are you in Crumley for athletics weekly
it's a question for more and Chris just
carrying on the theme of advice to Emil
obviously who hasn't sampled the full
Marathon yet what was the biggest
challenge around the distance that you
two discovered when you first stepped up
and and what would be the sort of the
biggest piece of advice to anyone sort
of taking on the distance for the first
time yeah um your debut was 14 wasn't it
we both did our debut together yeah so
my debut was back in 2014. and I think
the hardest thing is you know when you
see athletes who you know gone to the
marathon and what they run and they're
like so-and-so is running so Sooners run
this and sometimes you go okay if he
runs this time I can run it and I think
that was the hardest thing because
first marathon you should be able to go
okay I'm in great shape I'm good to go
I'm confident myself just go out there
and run your own race and just see how
you feel and get through it don't put
pressure on yourself where you go I'm
gonna go and run this time because when
you
put your pressure on there's a lot of
pressure and you you get to tense so
just run through go out there and as you
see the most marathons often it's not
always the best one straight away it
will be personal best but later on then
you can look back and go it felt great
at 30k
um I felt bad at 30k and you could learn
from and change your training from there
but first one go out there enjoy it and
set a personal best we'll
um yeah it's an interesting one that
because purely because I think
that shoot the way shoe Tech has changed
things it's changed into such an extent
that when I think back to my debut in
2014 around 211
and it's still to this day
the most emotional I probably shut your
ears because it doesn't there's a most
painful horrible excruciating like I
went to a place I've never been to
before
um that last two three miles all I could
see was Ryan bucks
uh backside and I was just trying to
stay as close to his him as possible and
I was
just everything that day was just a very
emotional very tough very and even the
training building up to it so Alan
coached me and Scott overall
um and I went through like it was I put
a level of expectation of what it what
marathon training was which was
unrealistic and what I expect I almost
took my track
experience and thought I've just got to
run like a train like a 10K Runner but
use that intensity Marathon it was a bit
unrealistic and it was tough
um and I don't think it's like that
anymore I think the shoes have even for
me I'm just trying to understand the
shoes and my point I'm trying to get to
is I think
these days I think Marathon experiences
are unique they're different they're not
they're not they're tough in a different
way and I think that's where for someone
like you going into this it's you can be
a little bit more open-minded and it's
not necessarily you versus the event I
felt like it was a challenge between me
and a marathon whereas now
we don't know what the best way to
operate with these shoes are we don't
know that
Marathon running is still being blown
open in my opinion and I think you're a
part of an exciting generation that
that almost like what I learned is kind
of almost becomes irrelevant
um because you can do so much more
um a meaning for this Marathon I've
trained completely differently because
the shoe Tech gives you more
um if I try to train like I did for a
211 guy when I back in the day I
wouldn't survive because it would just
be too tough so I think it's kind of a
difficult one and I think for you just
be open-minded experiment play around
with it be the first athlete to figure
out the best way to run with these
things because I don't think I don't
think I think the best I know the Inga
britons have kind of played around with
double days and it's becoming the thing
to do double thresholds and all these
things
um crikey back in the back then you did
double day you'd be in bed for two weeks
um so yeah just play around with it see
what you can do and shock us do it I
hope your mom's got super shoes for
Sunday as well I didn't know I said no
she just needs to get around
so we are a little bit pressed for time
I know one of some of the press of
one-to-ones with yourselves after this
but we do have some online questions
that Ryan from our press team is going
to read out down to you Ryan
Thanks James yeah first up is Michael
from talksport and he has a question
from Mo which is which would you prefer
Arsenal to win the Premier League this
season or to win the marathon on Sunday
Arsenal
really come on though no I'm joking
sometimes I want to answer that one
um honestly
yeah
it's tough one now
well I think the question is are they
going to win it regardless of what
happens to you on Sunday
it's been illegal on Sunday
winning the league will also win the
league
no where's London I would say in London
um yeah
what a terrible fan you are yeah
and we have a question for a meal from
Jack from the Independent which is
what's the process been for deciding
your strategy on debut will you be
conservative with the potential to go
again in the autumn and winter is our
second Marathon planned for later in the
year perhaps Valencia
yeah I think uh in the planet at the
moment is doing Valencia in December
um if if everything goes how our hope it
goes and then with regards to their this
weekend yeah probably somewhere in
between being conservative and
aggressive just so I'm just feeling all
the rest and not doing anything silly I
think is the pun
and so that's it I think from our top
three thank you very much you're not
even gonna make one up for me
to you Chris and uh thank you Mo so uh
yeah best of luck for the TCS London
marathon on Sunday I'm sure there's
gonna be loads of people we're in the
masteries and the Masters race is going
to be uh much anticipated what's the
Masters British record uh is it Andy
Andy Davis's 215 yeah so that might have
gone good chance for that one which
we'll have a Sprint I have it already
like what have you run since you're 40.
for them for the marathon no because Q
was like the week two weeks before my
birthday and then
um I had Visa issues and illnesses so I
didn't run the next thing so I think so
I haven't run a marathon since I've
turned 40 actually 215 so I think that
that could be on borrowed time so thank
you again to the three of you and uh we
return at three o'clock we have uh
International men's uh press conference
we have defending Champion Amos kit Ruto
we have the world champion Tama Tola and
we have the fastest debutant of all time
that's Kelvin Kipton coming up at three
o'clock so thank you very much to our
media thank you very much to Mo Chris
and Emil thank you thank you guys
foreign